The Joe Rogan experience from 81 to 88 all I did was taekwondo.
That's all I did.
Dodged it all.
February,
1919 79 was the day my life went downhill.
You know why?
Why I got my one,
I want a form in a karate tournament.
I was a purple belt.
I was in the eighth grade and then I lost the fighting.
I got disqualified for kicking above the fucking face.
You were really young.
How old were you?
I was 13 or 14 it was on my contact and I got out of Goshen,
rue karate and you know,
I liked those guys.
That's why I missed that whole thing because on the weekends we just got a
different fucking tournament's.
You know when you do that?
When I was a kid,
you just go to different tournament's.
On Saturdays we would all geek out and go to Honda.
You know what a Honda is in New York?
That's a big martial arts supplies.
Yeah.
I would geek out now,
like I get to Lynn checks on neutron stars,
caboodle,
Tom Flores.
I get the fucking things that you can punch the clock.
She's Maki Juarez.
I had to fucking the fucking
the fucking thing.
The juice you put on your palms.
Yeah,
I was the real deal.
You know that was watching Chinese connection was the last time you want Chinese
guy tonight when everybody goes to sleep put on Bruce Lee's second movie.
Do me that favor.
Give me that fucking famous and you're going to see what fucking unreal is.
Put up some Bruce leads.
You're going to see the last scene of Chinese connection.
The last scene when he goes into the school,
listen to what he says.
Remember Chinese connection is,
is kind of a rip off of the Spaghetti Westerns.
If you watch those three movies Clay's would made in Italy.
There's so far with gun like you haven't watched them in 20 years watching the
good,
the bad,
and yet what's the tiny paint?
The town red.
I don't remember that.
That was a great,
that was a great move to came back as a ghost.
Stories,
a go story and Chinese connection.
He comes back as a student that they kill his teacher and he avenges his teacher
and it just the new chuck scene and the Chinese connection.
When he first attacks the school,
when he goes in and he goes,
I'm allowing you to leave.
Who allows you to leave?
Even in Bronx Tale,
they lock the fucking door and they wouldn't let the bike is.
Leave this right here.
Look at this.
This changed America forever.
This was 1970 look at this guys.
Watch this.
I still remember the fucking commercial for this.
The trailer.
Look at how slow and methodical,
look at this man.
Ladies and gentlemen,
look at him
and they all live with Steve Mcqueen head and Steve Mcqueen was when he had you
talk about Lee is forearms.
This guy's crowns was seven times the size of a man and nobody had ever see
anybody kicking like this before.
1970 nobody ever seen nothing like this.
I remember being in Catholic school at sacred heart school for boys and seeing
this and losing my fucking mind,
but this isn't nothing.
I'm going to show you the scene with James America forever,
right here.
The double points for both of them right here.
Bam,
right here.
This changed America forever,
Ladies and gentlemen,
that double.
Nobody's ever done that right chest.
When they say,
why watch all this says Joe Rogan.
This is all beauty.
This will never happen again.
All right,
this is an American chains for it.
Oh,
one guy hit him in the back.
This fucked up.
He's forever.
Right here.
The Guy fucked up.
He kicks him in the bathroom.
It was 1970 nobody had ever seen new in Chauvet before that.
How many times you hit yourself on the back of the head?
Do a new trucks rob.
Man in the back of my head with bruises.
Fuck.
I probably have more PTSD.
Forget get hit in the head by my own nunchucks chucks ever getting punched my
man fucking hard.
Those Coco Bolo ones from centrally martial arts supply,
Coco Bolo,
nunchucks they were fucking like a pound each.
They bounce off the back of your head.
I still feel knots in my head.
I still feel knots in bag in my head from what
you supposed to go up and catch it behind you.
But I was going this way and catching it like that.
I was,
I didn't know what I was doing.
I was ad libbing,
whacking myself on the back of the head,
just going,
oh fuck.
And then right back to it.
This is just this,
this is too much.
I remember still going back to school that Monday and kids will lose me.
I still remember the drive in theater.
I saw this set.
We'll put that final fight scene because that's one of the greatest,
he jumps over a table and flying sidekicks,
motherfucker.
No stocks,
no nothing.
He gets the tastes of from a guy born.
He fights.
This is the end.
When they got to kill them.
Look at Bruce Lee and he just stands there looking at me.
Fucking just runs out of its before.
Is he single handedly
made being Chinese sexy
Donk,
donk,
donk.
Ah,
that's the song.
But Ah,
ah,
ah.
This is my life dog.
Who would stay at the movie theaters till midnight Til fucking midnight.
We'd
just just,
this is just too much.
Yeah.
I don't think anybody today
Jay can realize what an impact that guy had on kids.
I was living in Newark and I was at an apartment building and uh,
the superintendent of the building,
his kid was my age.
I used to go over his house.
That's how I found out about Bruce Lee hit him in his,
he had an older brother and they were really into Bruce Lee and they were,
you know,
you have like Bruce Lee posters and shit.
And I was like,
Whoa,
what is this Bruce Lee chef here you guys are into?
And then from there,
I'm pretty sure we went to see a movie together.
I think we went,
it was dad.
That was the first time I was exposed to it.
I was like,
maybe five or six and I was like,
oh my God.
He taught this country so many fucking things at the time.
Like people would just,
you know,
made everybody,
but it even strengthened like rebellious.
Like if you watch enter the dragon,
there's a part of that.
You never caught this as a pointless to a dragon with a guy comes in Bob Wall
and he goes,
I know Bob.
He goes,
you must attend the morning ritual and uniform.
Who?
She tells him outside,
he throws the punches and shit and the next day he's dressed in white dick about
that.
Everybody had a gian.
Brucely refused to wear a fucking gain.
It wasn't Eddie's grandfather.
He just refused to wear a fucking g.
That's the kind of mentality you put in these kids.
That's why these kids are getting bit slap.
Do you think it Brucey was around lake people be getting bullied?
Nobody got bullied when I was a kid because you watch Bruce Lee,
Bro,
he gave you fucking walls.
Would you please put that last [inaudible] talking about this?
I got bullied.
They got bullied by people who are trying to be brutally to connection,
fire fighting in the end.
Trust me,
it's on it.
I just watched it the other day on Youtube.
I was watching this shit the other day crying.
This is tremendous.
Brothers.
It's hard to look back when you look back at that and see the kind of impact
that had at the time.
It's just,
it's hard to wrap your head around it because nobody had ever seen anything like
that before.
There had been no karate movies and all of a sudden,
I mean,
maybe there was a couple,
but it was nothing like five fingers of death came out.
There was a two or three then this guy in Vail and the beauty of this was,
and I told us I want to Ari's storytellers,
that especially for me dog,
you know,
before Bruce Lee,
everybody was walk Chinese people,
especially with walking around,
they were the help bro.
They would've fucking helped.
He walked around half retarded.
This leak came out.
Bruce,
they high in his shirts and bowing that motherfuckers,
Bruce Lee came on and gave them this inner strength.
But for me,
I wasn't in Chinese.
I was Cuban,
I was an immigrant.
I knew what it was to walk around feeling like you.
And number two.
So for me,
he fucking strengthen my head just watching that shit like that Chinese
motherfucker do that.
I could do that.
Then my stepfather would come home cause I used to go to karate and my
stepfather go,
what'd you learn today?
And I teach them,
they go don't work on me.
And I go what the fuck are you?
You know what I'm saying?
It just worked at the karate school and don't work here.
And he would tell him,
you know why no one,
cause I smacked the shit out of Bruce Lee and Cuba one time and I believe him.
Why is he would tell them I fucked Bruce Lee up one time on the corner cube.
I bitch slept in that.
That Chinese guy,
he was bullshitting me.
The man,
my mother would tell me Batman was a Faggot,
you know shit like that [inaudible] scene.
That's it.
Oh no,
that's the,
you got to speed it up a little bit more.
But what?
Fuck,
we'll take that too.
What's this one?
He was also the first guy that was like really shredded like that and movies
were taking showers is a good place.
There's when he fights Mrs Suzuki,
this is what the saw,
look at this guys.
This is just tremendous.
Was there ever a guy that was like shirtless and movies?
It was flexing before him.
Was that a thing?
Does the guy was ripped Hercules.
Yeah,
but not like a fighter guy.
Right?
Tarzan.
Because everything else was after like a hard times Bronson.
That was much later.
Right.
Oh look at this fight.
Look at his fight.
He will will Ferrell,
but not just play this fight off the Joe.
There's one scene in here where you look at him and you go,
well you know why he couldn't be fake,
but look at his hand speed.
There wasn't no speed ups and filming this.
There wasn't nothing this fight with this.
This guy I think was a Russian that was coming to visit them,
but this just tremendous hole
from the fucking time he walks in.
It's a 20 minute fight.
The first movie does is a spinning elbow front.
Kay.
Who does that?
So he walked,
he walked.
There was two Japanese is right here.
We can see it right here.
No,
before that he goes like this.
He walks up.
Yeah.
You gotta get to the microphone,
man.
They don't do that shit no more.
Don't do that shit.
Put that.
I didn't even hear what you said.
He's playing the sound and you're talking to months.
All this shit.
Oh my God.
The guy,
the white belt.
What's his,
what's his hammer?
What's the speed?
Watch his fucking speed dog.
This is 1970 there was no speed up films.
It's also the sounds that he made but crazy.
Don't play that music.
Fine.
Watch this spinning.
What's this?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Pressing.
Watch this band.
This motherfucker didn't stop.
Now this fight scene by Ho sensibly
the movie theaters at my boys and we watched this and then we'd go next door to
mark was Donald's fruits and we knock all the fucking food plots.
Why would the guy got him in the arm up,
bro?
This is real.
This is 20 Oh my God.
Bruce Lee.
He fucked up that guy.
Had any technique.
What do you do?
They bite him.
He let go because of a bite.
He bit him in the fucking ankle.
Real fucking hard.
This kid arm bar technique for 1970 or whatever it was.
What year was this?
Just came out?
This was the original heroin movie.
Just came out like in 70 [inaudible] look at him.
Dogs.
They starts trending.
This motherfucker was asked if you ever watched the challenge detection,
you're fucking up.
And he's like Steve McQueen.
I mean 10 minutes.
Cause he's really angry in this movie because they killed his teaching.
He's fucking up.
I hate this fucking movie.
Who's on the phone with Steve Mcqueen?
Sleek.
Me mean talking to him.
Tell him what do I do next?
Beat the fuck up that.
Watch this.
This Steve McQueen's in the movies and we were standing.
Bow is buses.
Joe Rogan watch this.
Joe Rogan.
Oh,
come on now.
That guy just ate a wheel kit.
This is unrealistic.
It's that quick.
But the guy when you get wheeled,
you're gonna face.
Dude,
nobody would start shit bro.
It's,
this is awesome though.
This is tremendous.
It was the last time you saw this still good.
Well wait,
wait.
The wait the wait this fucking seat.
This is just too much.
You know,
look,
his technique is really fucking good.
It's really good to this day.
I mean,
it's hard to see someone do martial arts from back then and compare it to what
you see today.
But Bruce Lee compares.
It's really good kicking technique,
man.
Like his sidekick it straight.
He's not kicking,
I don't know if he's hit comes up,
it goes straight.
That's where it gets good with Faiza.
Fuck this motherfucker up right now for Joe Rogan.
Zukie was this Joe Rogan.
Watch this.
Watch this dog,
old school,
old school fucked up.
[inaudible]
fuck dog.
They makes it crazy screen when he karate act now he goes
after Suzuki.
He fucks up Suzuki.
Then it goes back to the school and they tell him,
you know,
you gotta go do some time and he fucking grabs the guy and he goes,
listen,
don't touch my school.
I'll fuck you up.
Then he walks outside.
He agreed to do time.
This is the beauty about Bruce Lee.
He's agreed to do the time.
He walks out and he opens the door and they're all there to shoot him.
That's the scene you see.
He could have turned around and ran away.
That motherfucker looked at him.
Yellville ran out into the audience and it ends with him doing a fly psychic and
you hear the bullets going on and you're just ready to go kill somebody.
At that point it's midnight and I'm going to tell them on a fuck.
I'm fucking somebody up tonight.
And that's how he left you off.
That was it.
And then return to the dragon came out with Chuck Norris and that was kind of,
ah,
people,
pat can let me know.
He didn't die.
It enter the dragon came out July of 73 and he was dead.
Maybe a week later.
He died a week after until the dragon came out.
He died July something [inaudible] 73 so I was 10 let me tell you something.
When he died,
you have no idea what this country was like because there was no internet.
You had to find out by going to Chinatown.
That was the proof.
You've got to go to Chinatown and buy the magazines and they showed you the
black and white pictures of him.
They carried him and his wake,
Kareem Abdul Jabbar and James Coburn.
It wasn't,
there was no newspaper.
Nobody cared about some Chinese guy that was,
we didn't find that until a month after he died that they sent us the letter by
the fucking in a bottle with a note.
You know what's really fascinating about him,
man,
he made his movies and all of his like scenes with these wild kicks and jumping
fine techniques,
but in real life when he practiced martial arts for fighting for like,
he never did any of that stuff.
He concentrated on like low kicks and punches and boxing techniques mixed with
wrestling techniques,
but he just knew that it would be spectacular looking spectacular.
Yeah.
Jody is Adam's his time.
Got You.
Really want to get to society way that to the film industry.
What he did,
he brought something that was just brilliant and then you watch enter the
dragon.
When they just cashed them out.
They just said,
listen,
you're coming back with us.
And then the Chinese people got mad and that was heroin money.
They made those movies for $10 and Thailand or what the fuck?
So he had some sort of crazy,
there's some crazy conspiracy theory about his death that it was the absolute
Chinese mob that killed him because he owed money and money.
He just took money out of their pocket.
When he left,
he went out with a born abroad.
You think that's what happened?
Did they kill us?
What happened?
If really what make them barrels and money?
How much money do you think the Chinese connection costs to shoot what they
think they paid those Thailand people?
Well,
it's kind of crazy when you find out this son died as well and died because
there was a bullet in a gun was supposed to be a blank gun or it had a piece in
it or something like that.
There's something in it.
If you were thinking like that,
some really crazy,
really rich Chinese gangster guy won his son dead as well.
Some real old school kingus Khan type shit.
Kill the man and then and then put a hit on his son and that,
that's how it went down.
I mean,
I don't know what happened to him.
I don't know.
But that's always been the conspiracy theory.
It's people,
you know,
people love those kinds of crazy stories.
They love the crank.
Crazy story of,
you know,
a curse
on him or,
or thought about milk.
Crucial.
The Samurai touches back like getting
touched him with the murder touch.
But it is crazy.
We've got a blood clot,
Brandon believe was killed.
I thought it was this,
this was my philosophy on it.
The Dea never talks about heroin coming from Chinese.
Chinese been bringing heroin into this country since Jesus loves Chicago,
but they,
that's smart.
That's smart.
They don't flaunt it.
When you see a Chinese restaurant,
what do you see?
You see 50 people where you see white people in there serving and know the whole
family's in.
Then when you want a good Chinese restaurant,
what do you see?
You see the kid in the two kids doing homework at the table,
don't you?
The whole family runs it.
They all move in together.
They all do all that shit.
So they know they're not Puerto Rican is bro and not fucking I Italians that bio
Lincoln compliment.
Oh look at me.
They can keep it low that they never could get busted.
They have such a great system to try ads.
Those Chinese gangsters number that the mafia concept is not Italian.
It's Chinese.
It's shy fucking knees.
So Spaghetti,
well I don't know about so that yeah,
noodles.
Noodles came from China.
They brought her to Italy.
The Italians came over to China,
found noodles,
brought it back to Italy and said,
oh we made me and Balmy Migs.
We got them into,
there's some Chinese dragon or some power.
So I think that they made all this money in China.
Where were they made these movies?
Cause after that the producers are hit and we're running low on shore and
Raymond Chow,
Raymond Shaft,
the Bruce Lee die.
Raymond shot became a break partner wanting to brothers.
In fact,
he produced a bunch of Charles Bronson movies.
Wow.
You understand me?
So there was a lot of Kinky shit going on.
And then 30 years later they killed his son.
If you watch godfather two,
what does he do?
He kills the fucking son's.
He lets veto live.
Vito goes back to the United States,
gets Powell and comes back and tells the by,
uh,
by bye.
Uh,
turn the machine on to the top price.
They're not going to stink.
Those are good for you.
Out of your foes are salmon flux,
bro.
There's something wrong with your nose.
Go to a dog.
There's a salmon.
I did a little him smelling,
therefore,
it's terrible art.
So bear forest in your faith.
You don't have to turn it on.
Really just sit down.
Gotcha.
That's glued a call with some m four is protein in that mother fucker.
Oh,
okay.
[inaudible].